the NASCAR Cup Series returning with the
real heroes 400 at Darlington Raceway
this Sunday and the driver of the famed
43 car for Richard Petty Motorsports
Bubba Wallace here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you sir
I'm all good yeah we are I mean that's
that is that is the ultimate right Bubba
I mean that is the absolute ultimate and
so I guess the question for you is you
are you are healthy right going into
this race on Sunday yes healthy as I can
be right now you know obviously we're
all kind of on eggshells and and like
the whole screening process and what's
going to go down and what takes place
and and it's just kind of nerve-wracking
just because you know if the one driver
has it and can all kind of be pulled out
from underneath that driver so we're all
just trying to take extra extra measures
to be ready mentally physically
emotionally so it's been a long time off
for us
usually we're we're kind of bored in the
offseason which we had just gotten off
of you know in January and then it seems
like we went back rates in for like two
weeks and then been sitting off for
another offseason so we are we're
excited we're ready to get back rollin
and counting down the days and hours
well if you don't mind I'd like to get a
little detailed with you about the
health and safety and the and the public
health issues that that you're you're
right in the middle of right now because
it's not only just fascinating to know
what you're going through and how you're
preparing because eventually you're
gonna have to compete but a lot of
sports might be looking in the direction
in NASCAR let's see how this works so
how is it working yeah I think we're
have you been tested sure for how this
goes and so there's are gonna be a lot
of eyes watching us one because sports
are back on TV yep and two because there
are going to be some out there that want
to see us fail and Kankan it pick at
every little thing if we don't follow
the right guidelines so we have had
multiple calls and NASCAR's done a
tremendous job up to this point of
laying the guidelines down
and what they're being told from from
the health advisors and and people that
that are making the most important
health calls as making a social distance
as much as as much as possible you know
we are not allowed to really be in
contact with anybody once we are at the
racetrack we are ordered to self
quarantine ourselves whether that's in
our car we drove down in our motorhomes
that we're bringing down until minutes
before the race so we will have no
outside contact the only communication I
will have of my crew is via telephone
email zoom I think that's the new thing
nowadays so it it definitely going to be
different you know usually on race day
you get to spend you know 30 minutes
with your team just kind of debrief and
and go through the the ups and downs of
what they expect but here it
I'm literally coming going from my house
to my house on wheels to quarantine
myself some more so that's gonna be
definitely different okay have you been
tested for covert 19 I have not
you know I've been checking my
temperature and and understand as
minimum most contact as I can right but
I've been I've been fine up until this
point okay will you get tested before
you get in the car are you planning on
it yeah they will have a whole screening
process when we show up to the racetrack
and and so they have all the guidelines
in place and protocols in place to
weather it a driver does have of what
they need to do what they need to do
next steps so we we have a whole lot of
the things that we have to go through so
it'll be a process for sure sure Bubba
Wallace here on the Rich Eisen show so I
guess because we you know then
qualifying is out right I mean it did
then and practice times out you're just
gonna the next time you get in the car
and you're in Darlington is is when it's
time to race or is that gonna change yes
yeah I keep everybody the perfect hold
my beer watch this moment we're gonna go
out and just jump in and green flag
gonna drop so you know
for us or for new sports fans that don't
really pay attention a scar we have
usually about a three days schedule
where we pick the practice in qualifying
and get the set up underneath the skits
come in and make adjustments and then
line up for the race hopefully with the
best possible setup well for us we're
going off last year's race the dart
Darlington which was which was in
September so there's there's a lot of
races in between that and our cars have
changed you're a tremendous amount with
upgrades and new this new that and so
we're all kind of worried about those
first couple of laps if we have our
travels right if we have to set up close
enough to where we can be competitive so
without all that practicing and and peak
time it's definitely going to throw a
curveball and things but hey that's why
we're some of the best in the world of
stock car racing so we're gonna give it
our all of course and and do you think
that you and your colleagues might be
more cautious because of all this setup
or what are you expecting Sunday to be
bother okay I've gotten that question a
lot I think I think we're all gonna kind
of be mindful yeah we don't really know
what our car is gonna do diving off into
turn one one of the most craziest
historic places such as Darlington so
we'll all be cautious and know what we
got but there will be a time without
that switch is flipped probably that lap
- I'm not sure but we'll hopefully take
it a little easy and and then get some
race underneath us so Bubba Wallace here
on the Rich Eisen show just just to
repeat you are not in physical proximity
or contact with any of the rest of your
team you are by yourself and you will
not be allowed to be in proximity of
anybody with your team until it's time
to race on Sunday and then you're gonna
go here than that I think yeah I think
we'll still go through what all's going
to happen but I won't see or talk to
anybody physically it'll be through bone
or from a very safe distance we will be
separated
we are told if the race is at 3:30 we
are told to be strapped in our cars at
3:20 and we leave our bus at 3:19 like
it's it's that critical and that strict
on who's around what time we have to
walk'n moved so it's they've gotten down
to a tee and I would hate to be them in
these in this time and leading up to
this time now I'm sure they've been up
day and night nascar miss week and
they've been up day and night trying to
figure out how we can get racing back in
front of fans you know and and and you
know there won't be any fans this time
how weird is that gonna be do you think
how weird is that gonna be it's gonna be
different but I thought a couple people
looks like a glorified test session so
when we were allowed to test we would
have some pre-season testing and and the
last one I did with last year and in
January in January at Vegas and there
was 20-plus teams there there was very
little fans just because it was you know
the middle of the week but but I think
it's gonna be like that but now you know
something that we are it's going to be a
test session for the first couple laps
but then we know that when the checkered
flag Falls there's gonna be a race
winner and they will get moved into the
playoffs so it's uh there's a lot more
on the line than just a test session but
I think I think we also look at it as on
our practice and qualifying days there's
there's not many fans that are in the
stands right it definitely ought to be a
ghost town that's gonna be weird for
sure but that doesn't change for sure
doesn't change my competitive
competitiveness we're still gonna go out
there and give it our all how much
contact have you had with your racing
colleagues everybody else is going to be
in the same position as you Sunday how
much contact you had with them the other
drivers yeah we have group chats that
we're all a part of and you know we had
just jumped off a call with with the
sanctioning body and all this drivers
that were in trying to get our last
couple of eyes dotted and t's crossed
before we head down there but I think
everybody's just excited to get back
going we uh when there was a lot of
speculation when this first started
happening of you know not racing at all
or whatever the circumstances could be
and I think this is the best scenario
possible for everybody involved
and it it's it's a really big deal for
sports almost also said it's the most
people it's crazy to realize how many
people in the world need sports
until you take it all away you never see
that so for me you know there's no
sports being around I was okay with
obviously I'm racing and I'm busy but I
didn't pay attention really until
September 1st when college football
started back up I mean who's calling
football fans sorry it feels like this
is kind of a norm to me but seeing that
there is absolutely nothing and how
people are going crazy over this and I
think it's a huge moment for us to kind
of lead sports teams and sanctioning
bodies back into the arenas and
racetracks and stadiums with or without
fans we got to do it the safe and
healthiest way possible so we will be I
wouldn't call it the test dummy or the
guinea pig that's what it is we got to
do our best best job
well it sounds Baba best you have
recounted here you know this is not
being done slipshod it's being done in a
way that that is you know buttoned up as
best you can I mean and again the phrase
being best you can is is the phrase I
know earlier you'd mentioned also in the
conversation that you think there's some
people potentially rooting for the
failure of NASCAR I wear are you picking
that up from I'm hoping this you stick
the landing here and other sports say
okay
NASCAR what are you doing so we can do
this too and you could you could drop it
if you will or let the green flag fly on
many other sports if this works out Baba
oh absolutely I'm saying there's gonna
be those people that are out there like
oh they are not six feet apart they're
5.9 feet you know it it's gonna be those
type of you I think like I said we're
all excited for sports to get back under
way but we have to you know be careful
and and manage every everything we do is
under a microscope right now and we know
that there's going to be extra eyes on
us mm-hmm to see how we handle each and
every circumstance that comes out of so
from from the EMTs being around it the
driver gets into Iraq or the the winner
you know the interview process is
totally there for note no crew around it
it's all different so and and NASCAR is
really you know it's it's more of the
health officials that are
coming to the track and making sure that
this all goes smoothly as well so this
isn't just like a game plan that we had
scripted up they have done numerous
amounts of work and research and
conversation emails you name it with
health officials and following the CDC
guidelines and allowing us to get back
and state officials and so many people
that are above my paygrade that high I
do not envy right now that are making
this all happen so we have to do an
exceptional job I'd like to ask you I
know it's a thorny subject but have you
spoken to Kyle Larson lately what's your
relationship with him like right now I
have not I have not spoken them so yeah
incident with them okay look man Bubba
I'm rooting for you and I'm rooting for
your sport I'm rooting for all your
drivers let it be safe and let it be
sound and let's let's do this I mean
let's let's race and see how it goes and
I'm appreciative of you well you know
wanting to do it and I guess that's my
last question for you is what's your
emotion right now yeah we're ready we're
counting down the days and the hours
really and just kind of figuring out you
know when to be there we still have some
the media media obligations and sponsor
obligations to fulfill on Sunday for
race day just like normal through
telephone and and FaceTime and zoo
meetings and stuff like that so it's
just gonna be a different take and I
think everybody's anxious and excited
for that but when it comes to the racing
stuff we've been doing this for a really
long time and this break it has a
pitching and ready for racing more than
ever and to show a new fan base that
we'll be watching is exciting for us
this show so to show them a great
product of racing is also important to
us and put on the best show possible so
I know there's gonna be 40 of us
competitive hungry drivers out there all
going for win okay and I guess last one
for you you're from Mobile and you said
your college
does that make you all burn or Alabama
Baba I am Tennessee believe it or not
okay
all right my mom my mom ran track their
identities in my blood my family's from
from Tennessee not carrying on Nashville
so yeah that's your vol that's your SEC
affiliation okay very good for mobile
and I figured that would be an easy
question to ask and get I didn't expect
that answer hey Bob well good luck to
you be safe be sound be healthy and and
and race race like the wind sir I will
appreciate it thank you for the for the
call that's Bubba Wallace hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here